maintaining a normal social life as a
Slayer it's problematic at best
it's the 90s the 1990s in point of fact
and I can do both
Kent has a job I just want to go on a
date well I suppose it was a fairly slim
lead thank you thank you thank you and
look I will
oh Sarah Michelle Geller got a lot of
experience protecting the world from
evil as Buffy the Vampire Slayer you
remember that for Seven Seasons she was
on the air now we're happy to tell you
Geller is back on TV screens in the
series it's called wolf pack it's on
Paramount plus which like CBS is a
division of Paramount Global we like
that she's a member of the family Geller
plays Kristen Ramsey and investigator is
trying to get to the bottom of a new
Supernatural danger that emerges during
a wildfire what is happening here take a
look
you're the head nurse
no but I can try to help you actually
know anything you can waste my time
I'm investigator Ramsey with the lafd
and this blunt instrument of the LAPD is
Officer Chang we're part of a Joint Task
Force investigating the wildfires we're
looking for anyone who came in recently
that was injured on the freeway this
morning especially the kids who were on
med school bus yeah we got one of them
walked in on his own laying Everett Lane
why would the police want to talk to him
Sarah Michelle Geller we're also happy
to tell you as an executive producer on
the show and joins us in the studio
hello Sarah Michelle
I'm in trouble tonight I'm in trouble no
before he went on the air I said how do
you prefer to be addressed Sarah is
Sarah Michelle and she said am I in
trouble I go no not that I know if she
goes well then just Sarah
the last 20 seconds
for Madame Geller so this is the thing
about this show one episode I guarantee
you guys you'll be hooked even if you're
not into this kind of Supernatural thing
because I I looked at one episode then I
said now I want to see what happens so
when the script came for you to play
agent Ramsey you said well I know this
stuff I can't wait to do it again that's
totally what happened obviously I get a
lot in that space yeah and initially I
had no plans to read it I was like I'm
gonna read it well no I I have done
vampires and we did it pretty
successfully I didn't feel the need to
repeat it and then my team said you
should just read it Jeff Davis who
created the show he's a really talented
writer and even if this isn't for you
like maybe you should meet maybe you
could do something and then like Gail I
read it and I was like wait I need to
know what happened what happens next and
what I came to realize and I've really
come to realize over the last couple of
months is that super human
Supernatural really allows you to tell
the most superhuman stories because you
kind of slip it in so yes while there is
obviously this bigger it's a metaphor
for really the demons in our head
because that's what scares us and you
know discussing anxiety discussing
loneliness the isolation we've all felt
and we can use sort of this world to
tell really important stories why was it
important to insert anxiety in this this
is also what I thought was interesting
well I think that the Youth of today
they face so much and I see it in my own
children I see it in myself you know we
have 24-hour news cycles and
everything's online and it's so much we
need to learn how to use it and what I
learned is that anxiety actually is your
body running at Peak condition and so if
we stop looking at it like a problem but
learn how to harness it that will
ultimately become our superpower so
teaching the youth to use that and also
just the idea of loneliness and the idea
of isolation that we all felt in covid
and how important your pack really is
everybody needs a pact
we do need a pack yeah you guys have a
pack yeah we do all right so someone on
our producing thought this would be an
important question to ask having played
a Vampire Slayer and now an investigator
hunting werewolves in life what would
you rather confront a werewolf or a
vampire
okay well a few things first of all you
know none of those are real
secondly that's I'm a fire investigator
I'm an arson investigator I'm just
looking who started the fire but you
know where it's going to lead do I
um
well no I don't understand I don't know
Sarah said first of all none of those
are real but that's such a good answer
well I mean wolves are real yeah and
there is a danger to wolves right now in
our environment which is the other thing
of the fires that's really interesting
so the last big now I'm from New York
obviously but I live in L.A now and the
last big fire we were that family at 2
am in the morning that they knocked on a
door and said you have 10 minutes to
evacuate and grab all your belongings
and we left with this huge fire coming
over the ridge not knowing if we were in
a house to come home too and thankfully
we we had a house to come back to a
dirty house but a house and we were
extremely grateful to all of the work
but you realize in that you know what
we're doing to our environment and not
just what it's doing to us but what it's
doing to all of the animals and the
ecosystem within yeah yeah you were
talking during the commercial break
about being an executive producer and
creating a work environment
did your past experiences put you in a
better position to have this safer place
for people to coexist well absolutely
what's experience and knowledge if you
can't use it pass it on and make things
better because of the experiences you've
had and you know I left the business for
a while to raise my kids and coming back
it is a different business that you're
coming to and being able to make a set
that's communicative that's
collaborative where voices can be heard
you know I understand that feelings
aren't facts but they're still feeling
there should be a place in any business
where you know we're so often told that
we're replaceable and just shut up and
say you're lying or do your job but you
could have a real concern and I want to
have a place where where people have
people to come to and I said to the kids
on the show I said look I'm not there
all the time I said here's my phone
number I always answer if there's a
concern like call me and I think they
were more comfortable talking to me than
other people because they understand and
also having an executive producer that's
odd you know you guys are lucky you have
your executive producer here every day
we don't usually have that in film and
especially in TV and so to have someone
that's on the set that knows what's
going on you know what we're working too
late we need to get get cards for people
so no one's driving or and the fact that
you said here's my number and call me
and you meant it and I even gave them my
real number yeah yeah I know I have okey
doke number two right that's good you
gave them the real number I gave them we
are cheering you on we are so excited
for this show and so excited for your
continued success thank you thank you
Sarah Michelle Geller We're Glad You
Came Here Wolfpack premieres this
Thursday on Paramount plus and we'll be
right back
you have an Okie doke number I didn't
know that